Universes collide in more ways than one in the new
"Spider-Verse" movie – and it definitely doesn't
happen the way you might expect. Warning: spoilers
ahead for "Spider-Man: Across the Spider-Verse."
Seeing as how the "Spider-Verse" follow-up
originally had a "Part One" as part of its
title, it's no surprise it ends by
setting up another sequel. But the
film has wide-ranging implications for the
future of other Spider-Man projects, too.
The movie contains many references
to Spider-Man projects of the past,
both hand-drawn and live-action. Viewers also
get to see clips – but not new material – from
Tobey Maguire and Andrew Garfield's versions
of the character. There's even a moment where
The Spot travels to the "Venom" universe,
speaking to Mrs. Chen for a little bit.
"So?"
However, arguably one of the best surprises
from the film is when Miles gets a tour of
Spider-Man 2099's compound and gets taken to
an area housing classic Spider-Man villains who
ended up in the wrong universe. There
are many great gags in this sequence,
including a moose version of Mysterio, but
fans will likely be most taken with a surprise
cameo from Donald Glover as a live-action
version of Prowler, complete with costume.
While this version of Prowler could have
come from anywhere in the multiverse,
fans won't forget that Glover already played
Prowler alter ego Aaron Davis in "Spider-Man:
Homecoming." A lot of time has
passed between that movie and now,
so it's possible he went from a low-level
criminal to a full-on supervillain, suggesting
a viable path for the next live-action
movie with Tom Holland's Spider-Man.
"Spider-Man" producer Amy Pascal recently hinted
that a live-action Miles Morales project is in the
works. Without further details, it's impossible
to say whether this would be part of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe or something separate within
Sony's wheelhouse, but Donald Glover's cameo
in "Across the Spider-Verse" could hint
at a storyline coming within the MCU..
Pascal also revealed that "Spider-Man
4" with Tom Holland is in the pipeline,
so it's possible Miles and Aaron could
have a story together in that film.
"I don't want those weapons in this
neighborhood. I got a nephew who live here."
While Holland's Peter Parker would likely have
a larger adversary to deal with, Glover's Uncle
Aaron could factor into the story somehow,
bringing Peter and Miles into contact with
one another. If Marvel wanted to keep the focus on
Peter Parker, it's possible Miles and Aaron would
only play smaller roles, with Miles getting bit
by the spider and facing the death of his uncle
in his own standalone film. Or we could see Miles
undergo the beginnings of his character arc in
"Spider-Man 4" before spinning off into another
movie, similarly to how Tom Holland initially
came onto the scene in "Captain America: Civil
War" before appearing in his first solo movie.
Then again, Glover's appearance in "Across
the Spider-Verse" may just function as a bit
of fan service and nothing more. More details
on "Spider-Man 4" and beyond probably won't
materialize until after the writers' strike
is over, so for now, fans can only speculate.
"And that's when the world went crazy."
Donald Glover has an intriguing
history with Spider-Man,
and even partly inspired the creation
of Miles Morales. So him popping up in
"Across the Spider-Verse" is a great
cameo for more reasons than one.
When the "Spider-Man" film franchise was
being rebooted with "The Amazing Spider-Man,"
Glover half-jokingly campaigned
to snag the role of Peter Parker,
even showing up with Spider-Man
pajamas in an episode of "Community."
The role ultimately went to Andrew Garfield, but
Glover did something arguably even more important.
Brian Michael Bendis and artist Sara Pichelli
were working on the "Ultimate Spider-Man" comic
when Glover inspired them to really create a
Black Spider-Man. Bendis even told USA Today,
"I saw him in the costume and thought,
'I would like to read that book.' So
I was glad I was writing that book."
Glover even voiced Miles for two episodes of
2015's "Ultimate Spider-Man" cartoon. As such,
it was appropriate casting to bring him
into the MCU as Miles' uncle, Aaron.
The creative team behind "Spider-Man: Far
From Home" even considered bringing Glover
back for a brief role, but it just didn't pan
out. Fortunately, Glover's cameo in "Across
the Spider-Verse" suggests the character could
still be out there, and if there's anyone who
should help usher Miles Morales into a live-action
setting, it should definitely be Donald Glover.